do you believe that Ukraine can achieve
Victory on the battlefield or do you
believe that ultimately you're going to
have to negotiate maybe even compromise
maybe even talk to Vladimir Putin and if
I may ask a second question please
um
20 around 20 of NATO's member states
have increased their defense spending or
made pledges to increase their defense
spending following the full-scale
invasion of Ukraine last year
would you like to see all 30 member
states increase their defense spending
given the need to continue to support
Ukraine and that does include the UK
which has yet to do that thank you
thank you for your question
if I forget something please make sure
to remind me
foreign
this important thing 20 countries is a
lot but there are so many countries
around the world who started to
uh increase their defense budget so this
is a complicated matter and requires a
complicated answer there was a previous
question how do you reform institutional
security globally and you are talking
about increase in defense budgets that's
the answer the war in Ukraine
gave rise to the resetting
everybody understood that the systems
are not perfect that we need something
more powerful and I'm not talking about
ammunition uh there's a lot spent
um on cyber security information
Independence Etc
Etc uavs
I.T cutting-edge Technologies
everybody's clear that
there's no cookie cutter approach
um probably other expenses are increased
as well but bottom line is that what
we're seeing now is the security system
being reformed and I think this is the
right step to take and
um
Everybody saw what we could expect from
the Russian Federation
and this brings us to the idea of
compromise and negotiations
we all saw that nobody ran to buy
flowers
instead everybody went to buy weapons
nobody wants to develop business with
Russian Federation more and more
sanctions appear sometimes sanctions
hurt but
everybody's clear now that they're
making you dependent on Russian gas and
if you are that dependent then you're
gonna get cold eventually uh because at
some point they might start thinking
that they want to uh to have their
people in your country they want a part
of your territory
and then people realize that we need
Independence not just on paper we need
real Independence to defend our people
because this is what that one person has
done with independent Ukraine who was a
neighbor and
um even sort of say a friend yesterday
so this brings me back to the first part
of your question after everybody saw
there that they killed people that they
torture people and they're not even
trying to hide their attacks
they're talking about
nuclear matters
they
decided to take Iranian drones and kill
civilians
and those civilians did not have guns in
their hands they had their children in
their hands
and seeing this picture of the world do
you think we ukrainians could sit at
this
to negotiate with all of this I don't
know how to call that we call this
phenomena rashism I I don't have a
better word to put it so that's that's
the answer
we
need to start from scratch we need to go
back to what was violated
our right to live on our land needs to
be respected leave our territory
withdraw stop shelling uh us stop
killing civilians stop destroying our
infrastructure energy sector potable
water stop
air strikes on the city stop killing
dogs cats animals stop burning the
forest
so you go ahead and stop doing all of
that and only after that we'll tell you
what format will be used to
diplomatically put an end to it